it's Jeff McDonald lead Spurs writer for
the San Antonio express-news he joins us
now he's been covering the team since
2007 alright Jeff how did we get to this
point with Kawhi Leonard in the Spurs
you know it sort of became almost a
snowball that was rolling downhill that
that I guess people didn't realize the
snowball was rolling until it was
rolling and then by the time you kind of
realized that it was it was an avalanche
but I think really the the disagreement
I guess or the rift would be about his
rehab from a quad injury that really
dates back to the season before last and
you know the he he wasn't I guess happy
or satisfied with the treatment he was
getting from the team medical staff and
so he took that he and his camp took
that into their own hands beginning in
August of last year and and it just
never got better and it led to some
frustration on the team side because
they weren't really getting the
information they thought you know they
were basically out of the loop on you
know their their franchise player and
there's really been just distrust sewn
on both sides of the issue and nothing
has really happened to close that gap
and in fact it seems to be widening and
that's sort of where we get to where we
are now as recently as March he was
still telling people he was planning on
playing last season he was even getting
specific his camp was getting specific
dates that he planned to be back on the
floor and then those dates would come
and go and his teammates were getting
kind of flummoxed by the whole deal
because Haeckel I said he was going to
play this game now he's not playing
where is he he's in New York rehabbing
he's not even in San Antonio and so it
just the resistance there's just this
this distrust and discord on each side
and then you get you start to look at it
from the Spurs perspective they grew
suspicious that perhaps this isn't even
really about the quad at all but it's a
it's a way for his camp to get him out
of San Antonio San Antonio altogether to
get him to a bit of bigger market and
that's sort of where we are today where
it appears that he is asking to be
shipped out of San Antonio
who
as leverage here that is an excellent
question I think both sides sort of have
a little bit of leverage when you're
talking about a trade because you know
Kauai can you know his contract is he
can opt out not this season but next
season two seasons from now so if the
team is going to trade for him and give
up assets for him and and great assets
for him they're going to want some
assurances that he's going to sign with
them long term so when you hear people
say well they should trade into Phoenix
for the number one overall pick and Josh
Jackson well the Phoenix want to give
the overall pick and Josh Jackson for a
guy they're going to have for basically
one year probably going after when
you're well probably not so Kauai has a
little leverage that way but if Kauai
only wants to go to the Lakers the Spurs
are under no obligation to only trade in
to the Lakers I mean they they can they
can trade into wherever they can get the
best deal and it's sort of a you know
how does it balance because you're going
to get better assets from a team where
Kauai might conceivably want to play
long-term as opposed to where he could
play short-term so I think both sides
have a little bit of leverage when it
comes to a trade HFI if I'm the Spurs
why would I give rap something to the
Lakers if I thought Paul George and
LeBron James we're gonna I don't want to
have kawaiii haunt me in a variety of
ways including you know on a more
frequent basis if he's still in the
Western Conference so why do we just
assume I know he wants to go to Los
Angeles but why do we just assume that
you know that deal could happen with the
Lakers and Spurs Yeah right I see I
think that's definitely part of the
calculus there and the other thing is
I'm not positive the Lakers can give the
best package of picks and and players I
think when you're the Spurs if you're
going to trade Kawhi Leonard obviously
you're not going to get a top five
player for him at this point so what
you're looking for probably is some
package of a guy or guys you might could
plausibly be considered future stars
future all-stars plus a lottery pick the
Lakers don't have picks their their
first-round pick is actually worse than
the number 18 if the Spurs have this
year and I don't believe the Lakers have
a first-round pick at all next year so
if the Spurs are looking for picks
the Lakers aren't really going to be
able to put together a package that
would entice them but I also think if
the Lakers if if there's no other market
for him if the Spurs can't get what
they're looking for from Boston or
Philly or someone else that you know
hasn't really been mentioned you got to
trade them to where you can get the best
players and if it makes the Lakers
better for a while it makes it like
there's better for a while I think if
you trade Kawhi Leonard probably at this
point in your the Spurs you're looking
at you're not a title contender anymore
anyway so what real difference does it
make if other teams are I mean I think
you've got I think if you're the Spurs
you've got to do the best you can do to
to get the most you can get back I just
don't think the Lakers are going to be
that team I mean they might be but I
don't think they're going to be how long
do you think pop would last with lonzo's
/ Lamar ball I think I think I think if
that trade were made on Monday pop would
retire on what happened but you know
they built a little of minutes with
Kawhi has been dealing with his uncle a
guy called Dennis Robertson who was
basically collides his agent he has an
agent but it's his business advisor but
Dennis Robertson is the one that's
basically running collides affairs right
now and there's there's definitely a
disconnect between between him and pop
and RC Buford they they're they I mean
the way I've described in Dennis
Robertson the people he's sort of like
levar ball except without all the
publicity you've never heard of him but
he behind the scenes he's that kind of
demanding character and that had that
relationship hasn't worked out well
between him and the Spurs brass for sure
how long is popular to do this you know
that's an excellent question to that
people have been asking for a long time
and I think everyone assumed you know
he's taken over Team USA in 2020 and we
always assumed that was going to be the
transition out of the NBA what's what's
sort of thrown a wild card and
everything is you know the personal
tragedy that he went through during the
playoffs and losing his wife and we
don't really know you know we're where
he is right now in terms of
next season from what I've heard he's
he's recently started to re-engage in
the you know day-to-day business of the
Spurs kind of the normal day-to-day
offseason stuff you know they were out
so early this year in April that
normally that up until about a couple
weeks ago he would have been kind of on
vacation and out of the loop anyway so I
have heard I have heard that he's sort
of starting to re-engage with the team
and and I say I believe at this point
there's they're expecting him to
continue and if that's true I stood I
think we go back to the other timetable
where he's transitioning into that team
u-s-a role in 2020 and so you know maybe
he takes a year off before that to kind
of calibrate himself maybe he goes right
into it but I I don't see um this is
just kind of neat guessing and me
talking but I don't really see him being
the coach of the Spurs and coaching in
the Olympics at the same time he could
do it if he wanted to there's no rule
against it I just it just seems natural
to me that that would be the transition
point and he's he's going to be seventy
I mean he's no you know it you know he's
getting to that age where you have to
think about anyway I remember he used to
talk about Jerry Sloan all the time me
and Jerry Sloan was his idol but he was
like I'm never gonna be a lifer like
Jerry Sloan I'm never gonna do that I
sounds horrible and all of a sudden
we're at age 70 and he's still he's
still going so I you know I I think the
end is near but I'm not sure to this
season all right I'll leave you with
this Jeff best case scenario I'm talking
to you in October Kawhi Leonard is where
best case scenario what do you think
yeah what do you think is is is the
what's most likely I don't think he's on
the Spurs but I couldn't at this point I
couldn't guess where he is but I think
there's a chance we may know before
Thursday when the draft happens so oh
really there's a chance I mean I think
if you're gonna trade him you want to
get in on this draft and get some of
these lottery picks so I think they're I
don't think they will rush anything but
I think there is definitely that's one
that's one that's one milepost you might
want to want to look at hitting if you
can do it is to you know get up there
the top two know this dress because it's
a pretty top-heavy dress well maybe
don't wait to October to talk to you
Jeff maybe I'm talking to hide a thank
you Jeff we appreciate your time
that's a Jeff McDonald the lead Spurs
beat writer for the San Antonio
express-news for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]